Perhaps no single artist has had a greater impact
on how we imagine alien life than Wayne Barlowe.
Widely considered the father of modern Speculative
Biology, Barlowe has worked for decades as a
creature designer for everything from Avatar to
Pacific Rim. Yet perhaps Barlow’s most monumental
alien world comes from his legendary book
‘Expedition’ — which depicts an extraterrestrial
ecosystem with so much originality and detail
that reading it truly feels like getting lost
on another planet. The book was even made into a
TV special for the Discovery Channel called ‘Alien
Planet,’ which was honestly one of my favorite
things to watch as a kid. The world at the center
of the book and documentary — called ‘Darwin
IV’ — is one I’ve wanted to document myself
for a long time. So, for this entry into the
archive, we’ll take a dive-deep into the biology
and ecosystems of Barlowe’s one-of-a-kind planet.
In honor of the book’s logbook-style storytelling,
this entry will be told as a firsthand account
of an expedition across Darwin IV’s surface.
And if you find the planet as incredible
as I do, I’ve got links below where you
can purchase his book and support his
work. Now, let’s begin our expedition…
My story begins with this single, blurry photo
taken by a faster-than-light probe exploring
the far reaches of the galaxy. The image shows
alien life is present in the fourth planet of
the distant Darwinian System. But what kind
of lifeform is this alien? How large is it?
And what other lifeforms might it coexist
with? There’s only one way to find out…
After a journey of many lightyears, I arrive at
Darwin IV. From orbit, my first scans indicate
the planet is a dry, hothouse world. The only
visible body of water is a peculiar, purple
ocean of unknown properties. Scans also indicate
Darwin IV possesses an oxygen-rich atmosphere
and less than two-thirds Earth’s gravity —
meaning life on Darwin IV may well be gigantic.
I’ll have to proceed carefully… Touching down
in the northern hemisphere, I find a sweeping
grassland dominated by titanic plant structures
called Gourd Trees. Nearly fifteen stories high,
these trees stand on a matrix of root-like
stilts. If these are the plants of this world,
the animals might be true titans… Not far from the
grove, something is squatting low to the ground.
Consulting the field guide of
an explorer who came before me,
I identify this creates as an Arrowtongue. While
it doesn’t appear to have eyes, a series of low
clicks tells me it can ‘see’ with an organic
sonar system — and likely knows I’m here.
Rearing up to its full height, the Arrowtongue
reveals it’s a t-rex sized apex predator.
Unlike all top earth predators, however, the
Arrowtongue doesn’t possess jaws. Instead,
it feeds with a straw-like appendage on its mouth
which is common among all ‘liquivores’ — a group
of tube-mouthed predators that includes the
Arrowtongue. And this Arrowtongue seems hungry…
…But not for me. The preferred food of an
Arrowtongue are the Gyrosprinters — herbivores
with highly unusual body-plans. While they spend
much of their time resting, they’re the fastest of
all land animals here. Yet the Gyrosprinters’
ability to careen across the grassland at
incredible speeds is a tricky thing, considering
that they only have two legs. To keep balance,
they possess a set of hyper-developed ‘halteres’
— club-shaped organs which earth animals like
craneflies use to keep their bodies stabilized
during motion. A key trait for the Gyrosprinter,
which must always be ready to flee. Speaking of
which, it’s best I leave these two to the chase…
Not far from this unfolding drama, I spot a
leathery Rayback trotting across the grassland.
A smaller relative of the colossal Arrowtongue,
the quick, solitary Raybacks are in many ways the
cheetahs of this alien savanna. Yet the Raybacks’
most notable features — their exaggerated dorsal
spires — are something of a biological enigma.
If we look at Earth animals for clues as to the
function of these spines, we find some chameleons
possess similar bony ridges to appear larger from
the side and to intimidate rivals. It’s a curious
strategy, but if it works for the chameleon,
it’s certainly possible it would work on Darwin
IV for the Rayback. Traveling northwards,
I’m lucky enough to glimpse a mighty hunter
standing triumphant over its latest quarry.
This ambush predator is called a Prairie-Ram, and
true to its name, this particular liquivore hunts
by ramming its prey with its pointed skull. While
no earth predators hunt in quite the same way,
some species have evolved to ram into each
other in territorial displays. In particular,
big horn sheep have evolved skulls and horns that
can absorb tremendous concussive force thanks to
their internal structure. We can theorize that the
interior of the Prairie-Rams skull likely has a
similar makeup… At the edge of the grasslands,
I watch a duo of mid-sized herbivores — called
prismalopes — graze in the shade of a curious
tree. But it’s not the prismalopes I’m focused
on. Upon closer inspection, the apparent ‘tree’
behind them doesn’t seem to be a plant at all.
This is a butcher tree, a lifeform with a deadly
secret. It’s scent lures in herbivores, and when
one gets close, the butchertree spears it with
its branch-daggers. Scans conform this lifeform
is closer to animal than plant. I better keep my
distance… Night is now falling on Darwin IV. And
in the darkness, the Prongheads stalk the savanna.
These well-muscled pack hunters are the wolves
of Darwin IV, and move with surprising speed.
Cresting a hill, I see what they’re hunting. The
gyrosprinter from earlier survived the chase with
the Arrowtongue, but is now in even more danger!
Racing across the plains, the gyrosprinter is
incredibly fast… but the Prongheads have the
numbers advantage. Unlike the Arrowtongue, they
can coordinate in a pack to cut off their prey…
But this gyrosprinter is a survivor, and
manages to give them the slip. On Darwin IV,
it pays to be the quickest. With the morning now
just a few hours away, I’ve made a significant
discovery. I’ve followed a lone Rayback beyond
the savanna to the edge of a mysterious forest.
This new environment might be home to all manner
of distinct lifeforms. But the only way to know
for sure is to venture deeper… I don’t have
to go far. On the periphery of the forest,
a huge creature shakes the ground, so tall that
it towers over the trees. This is a Groveback,
one of the largest species native to Darwin IV.
Strange tree-like structures grow from its back,
which might help the Groveback remain camouflaged
while it slumbers. Given the Groveback’s size,
however, it seems unlikely this creature would
fear predators. Instead, as the sun rises,
I wonder if perhaps the Groveback has a symbiotic
relationship with the plants on its back,
gaining energy from their photosynthesis much
like an earth ‘Leaf Sheep’ — a rare type of
sea slug that almost looks like a miniature
Groveback from certain angles. In any case,
the Grovebacks are truly awe-inspiring. I’ll have
to make sure they don’t step on me, though...
Deeper into the forest, I spot a curious lifeform
reclining on a branch far above me. This is a
Daggerwrist, an agile arboreal predator that
rules the upper treetops thanks to its deadly,
bladed proboscis — which is the closest thing to a
functioning jaw on Darwin IV. In a burst of speed,
the Daggerwrist leaps to another tree, scaling
the side of the trunk by using the claw-like
arms that are its namesake almost like climbing
spikes. And in the canopy, the Daggerwrist
rejoins a troop of its own kind. This family
unit is comprised of a young infant and two
parents — and their pack behavior showcases a
new side of Darwin life: social interaction.
While Daggerwrists might be deadly predators, like
earth monkeys it seems they are sociable, living
in troops of one or more families and looking out
for each other. After reuniting with its troop,
the Daggerwrist goes on the hunt once more,
and I get to witness it leaping from a tree
and gliding to the ground using sails under its
arms — soaring in a manner quite similar to many
species of gliding earth animals. The hunt doesn’t
last long. The Daggerwrist is a brutal hunter,
and an animal I should be wary of. On the other
edge of the forest, I see a lone Groveback that
seems to be under attack. The air is filled
with a swarm of needle like predators, which are
launching themselves at the titantic Groveback
from all directions. These are Beachquills,
and while it seems impossible for these small
lifeforms to take down such a behemoth, the
Groveback is clearly affected by their onslaught.
I realize the Beachquills must be highly toxic.
It might seem strange that tiny organisms
like Beachquills could be so venomous,
but animals like the tiny Bluespotted Ribbontail
Ray are some of the most venomous lifeforms in the
oceans — despite their small size. So, it makes
sense that a colony of Beachquills working in
tandem would be able to take down all number
of organisms that wander into their domain.
For the Beachquills mark the edge of a new biome —
one home to far greater dangers than the forest...
Two days into my expedition, I’ve reached a
sea of shifting purple liquid, the properties
of which are highly mysterious. This landscape
appears to be the same ocean I saw from space…
which now doesn’t seem to be an ocean at all. With
caution, I take a sample of this strange mass.
Looking under a field microscope, I find this
ocean isn’t made of water molecules — but living
cells. This entire ‘ocean’ is a single, massive
lifeform — an ‘Amoebic Sea’ that blankets about
5% of the surface of planet Darwin IV. Looking
towards the horizon, I can see this vast colony
stretches far into the distance, and is a biome
in and of itself. A question grows in my mind:
what lifeforms have evolved to live upon this
sentient ocean? A low roar thunders across the
sea. The mightiest creatures I will ever see
are approaching. At last, they come into view.
These are Emperor Sea Striders, the largest
lifeforms I’ve discovered on my voyage — towering
over the Amoebic Sea like living mountains.
Without a doubt, these are the creatures the
probe first glimpsed that started the entire
expedition — but seeing them in person is an
entirely different experience. In order
to sustain such an awe-inspiring size,
the Sea Strider’s biology is one of a kind
— particularly their feeding system. The
Sea Striders possess two mouth-like openings
located on their feet, allowing them to feed
on the limitless Amoebic Sea while they stride
across it. It’s the perfect food source for
such a vast lifeform. And though a storm rages
around them, the Emperor Sea Striders march on,
undaunted. In just a short time, I’ve seen more
wonders than I can count on the surface of Darwin
IV. Yet I suspect the mysteries of this planet are
just beginning… I’ll venture farther across Darwin
IV in Part Two of this expedition, investigating
the more extreme and often more dangerous life
of the skies and polar regions. If you have
a particular creature you want me to be sure
to cover, put it in the comments. If you find
the life of Darwin IV as fascinating as I do,
I’d encourage you to purchase the book and check
out more of Wayne Barlowe’s incredible work.
Once again, links are in the description. And
as always, thanks for watching. If you enjoyed
this entry, please lend your support to help make
these videos possible by liking, subscribing, and
hitting the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things Curious. See you in the next video.